[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in and you know
what time it is
it is the end of season fan q a as is
tradition we reached out to you guys on
twitter
we reached out to you guys on youtube we
reached out to you guys on instagram
and overwhelmingly understandably
most of the questions were all about the
lockdown
covid how does it affect the show how
will it affect the show going forward so
to start things off
i'll just try to over explain this and
give a state of the union
in regards to hot ones during this
lockdown
and i'll start by saying this doing the
show remotely
logistically everything about it it
sucks ass
no one wants to get back in the studio
worse than me
here's what's standing in the way of
that i know i've said it before but i
think some fans just don't really
understand that we travel
a lot to do this show during the course
of a season we might go from new york to
chicago to los angeles to london
to miami to atlanta and that's kind of
how the show pops around and how we're
able to get the guests that we get
and that's obviously just not a
realistic way to function right now
and even if we were bullish on it which
by the way i kind of am you know if i
if i could quarantine myself get tested
every day
sign a waiver take on my ability myself
i would do that to get a show
in the studio and to be able to do it
the problem is they're just too many
safety concerns liability concerns
protocol rules that touch
everything that we do from the company i
work for
to the studios we rent to the guests we
ask to be on the show
so the question i guess is this how do
we get out of this
the thing i'm keeping an eye on is late
night shows like when are guests gonna
get back on the couch when will daytime
shows have a live studio audience
guests who have concerns about their own
safety when will they feel comfortable
to come back into a studio setting
it's just a thing that's going to take
more time more data
and more information than i think any of
us signed up for when it first started i
know i didn't
originally i was like all right let's
try to buy a month and then we could
probably get back in the studio
obviously that's not a thing that's
happening right now but i do want to say
this because
my guess is if you're watching this q a
that you're
a real like hardcore day one fan and
that you've stuck with us through this
quarantine season
i want to say this thank you for your
patience
thank you for supporting us the way that
you've supported us this whole time it's
what keeps us going through what has
been
an extremely challenging season for us
on a production level
but look at boom boom you me you me
it's always been that way we're gonna
rock through this
we're gonna keep working hard to deliver
the interviews that you want are there
going to be audio issues
sure are there going to be random
quicktime data issues that get messed up
sure is it going to be a little bit
different doing an interview
where you don't have that face-to-face
human contact
chemistry and rhythm that's so important
when you're doing an interview show
sure and trust me when i say this no one
wants to get back in the studio worse
than i do
trust me on that we'll keep doing
pressure
do it the safest best way possible
and in the meantime we'll just send
wings to celebrities homes
have them over douse them uh with sauce
and have some of these like
crazy just anarchy at home episodes that
we've been doing
we will still work hard we will still
rock through we will still try to
deliver the best product possible
obviously in these times there are some
curveballs that we didn't ask for some
hurdles in the way that we didn't ask
for
we have to deal with it that's that
all right on to the q a
thank you for your patience let's answer
some of your questions it is the least
that i can do for you
thank you thank you thank you hot ones
fans
best fans alright first up amanda leske
from youtube
asks sean just between you and me who's
your favorite crew member i swear i
won't tell anyone
so it's been pretty much the same group
of eight people doing hot ones since day
one
lots of love and that team has pretty
much stayed
exactly intact since day one
that is until now we say goodbye to
somebody who is very special to us
and that is kristin price you might
recognize her as the goofball cranking
her head into frame and that migos joe
budden meme
but she's been our booker our secret
weapon a
assassin in the trenches of hot ones for
years
we will miss her so much kp i love you
thank you for everything that you ever
did to make hot ones what it is today
you'll never be replaced we wish you
luck
we will miss you i miss you already
all right up next noah scott asks what's
your favorite tv show right now
all right here's a quick breakdown of my
quarantine watching habits i've been
watching a lot of tv during quarantine
so here's
here are the shows that i like i like
better call saul
i like that showtime show with jim
carrey i like kidding
i like uh i may destroy you i like room
i like billions i've been watching
reruns of pawn stars
i've been watching nathan for you i've
uh i've been watching a lot of true
crime documentaries and podcasts
and uh i also like 80s like tough guy
movies like
like maybe this is a 90s movie but like
i like cliffhanger i like
goofy 80s comedies i like like revenge
of the nerds i like stripes
i like movies like that i don't know
that's i've been watching before i go to
bed every night
moniker addict asks in the age of
chronovirus do you feel the guess you've
had remotely have fared better or worse
without you there to guide them as their
spicy shaman
well one charming byproduct of these
quarantine episodes is that
you know we send people sauces and dom
will have like a whole
best practices thing printed out on how
we toss it with the bowls and stuff
clearly no one is reading that when
they get the
when they get that kit they just grab
the bottles out log in on the internet
and then bam they're connected with the
show dump and sauce is all over the
place
it has been absolute chaos in these
episodes and i feel helpless because i'm
just
staring at them at a monitor like
yelling through the screen to like
be careful around the eyes and like
watch how much they're dumping on so
if there's something that's been kind of
nice something that i've kind of
appreciated about the quarantine
episodes
first up all the different setups going
into people's homes
and then the absolute graceless chaotic
nature with which
these people are saucing wings it's been
fun to watch
all right up next alic rosier asks
are we gonna see more from camera guy
bill yes
right now in fact because we've got
bills to pay with bill
hey bill what are you doing during
quarantine
oh hey there sean great to hear from you
you know when i get a chance to hit the
reset button and chill
i like to do what relaxes me what takes
my mind off work
i love hot ones but i do have a life
outside of it you know
back to you sean
[Music]
all right up next mason popperling asks
have there ever been a potential guest
who walked out of the show at the last
minute
uh yeah it's been happening quite a bit
recently actually
so logistically doing these remote
episodes like the things that make them
such a pain in the ass is because
you know you're relying on like
quicktime and maybe there's like this
upload error and the audio gets messed
up and there's a feedback feeding
this thing through this and you book
somebody you got to make sure that they
can get all the sauces sent to their
home in time but the
biggest thing that is driving me insane
is people just
ghosting the interview because they're
not like on the circuit with like their
publicist holding their hand from place
to place
so there's been times this season where
i'm just standing here
in this studio with the lights on me
wings in front of me
waiting for somebody to come in through
the monitor and then it just doesn't
happen then we're like
calling up record labels and reps and
like where's this person where's that
person
today in fact i was supposed to shoot
something and then
nothing happened so i think that
happened like once in the five years
previous to doing the show
now it's just like kind of a thing that
happened so it's another another
charming byproduct of the times okay up
next
you know i mean like uh oh okay uh
they're sick they're sick but then
you're like on instagram live having a
great time in the studio
agreed to do the show he said sauce is
halfway across the world
uh and then all of a sudden day of i'm
not doing it i'm not doing it i'm not
doing it okay
then just you know say no that's fine
then we'll just go on to the next person
it's not that big of a deal it's okay
but but don't we have to send sauces out
now then we have no time
this thing gets canceled we don't have
an episode now
we got it takes three days to get sauces
somewhere two days to get sauces
somewhere all right you're pinching us
just say no we don't care it's okay
all right up next sabzi11 asks does
shawn have a favorite sauce he uses for
personal consumption that was featured
on the show
okay here's my official mount rushmore
of hot sauces
as of today not including any of the hot
one sauces i do love los calientes but
this is my
two day top four hot sauces my favorite
hot sauces
the ones that i use in my everyday life
are as follows
my favorite hot sauce of all time queen
majesties scotch bonnet and ginger
that's my favorite one and it's not all
that close the other heads
on the mount rushmore though are
shaquanda's green sass
headless horseradish from torch bearer
and then we've never had it on the show
but yellow bird which i believe
is an austin texas hot sauce label they
have this squeeze bottle technology
the habanero yellow bird hot sauce
chef's kiss all right david wilson asks
what are some youtube channels you
watching your down time
all right if you looked at my history
right now the things that i'm watching a
lot
watching a lot of your mom's house
podcast uh mark rober i like his videos
a lot
and then also john boy shout out my guy
john boy
he's the guy who does like he'll look at
like a weird baseball play and like read
lips or like a manager gets tossed he'll
read lips he breaks down baseball stuff
i love john boy those are my favorite
those are my favorite youtube channels
at the moment but that's just off the
top of my head
uh watching lots of youtube just like
watching lots of tv like everybody else
but those are three that come to mind
immediately adam horowitz asks
baseball or hockey baseball shout out to
my chicago white sox just hitting bombs
all over the place lucas giolito no
hitter last week
it's been awesome to watch very exciting
long overdue
and god did i need it but i'm a big fan
of the nhl playoffs always watch the
playoffs every game that i can love the
playoffs alright up next
matthew devine asks if you were a pro
wrestler what would your entrance song
be bonus question
what would your stage name be all right
so my name would be sean the magnificent
and i would do magic tricks i think that
that's really what professional
wrestling is missing right now is like a
david blaine element
so i'd go out there hat cape and i would
just do
violent magic tricks in the ring and
then my walkout music
would be blackrobs whoa
all right on that note that brings to an
end
another hot ones fan q a thank you so
much for sending in your
questions thank you so much for watching
and supporting us through this trying
challenging but together we can make it
season
and the next season of hot ones we're
taking a very short break
we'll premiere on october 1st
that's right just a few weeks off little
truth or dab
little hot sauce reveal and then we are
right back
to doing more episodes 10 1
hot ones returns again thank you very
much for watching
we'll see you next time in the dark
black box that they'll only let me and
steven hang out in
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
hot ones truth or dab the game is
finally here baby what's in the box
what's in the box what's in the box well
the kit comes complete with 250 question
cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice
just like in the show answer it honestly
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be careful be very careful
around the eyes hot ones truth or dab
the play at home game is available at
shop.firstwe fees.com
and heatness.com play at your own risk
wings not included